[Music]
I always imagine what the rest of the
world looked like outside of New Orleans
I was in a group after a particular gig
we saw that there was a performance
going on at the S theater Brian mcnight
featuring Tyrese and we just decided to
go on the side of the building and just
start singing hoping somebody would
notice us that's exactly what happened
my manager now who was managing uh
Tyrese at the time was there that's how
I got to La
[Music]
Boom
I can't really say when I fell in love
with music I think I always wanted to be
an Entertainer and I just saw how music
moved people and I just wanted to do
that right now we are at the Village
Studio this studio has an amazing
history I mean The Chronic was recorded
here doggy style was recorded here and
just has a great Vibe for creating more
more more you feel closer than before
now there's no going
music is a feeling everyone feels it
it's something we all can relate to
music is the only language that speaks
directly directly to your soul it has
all the
answers I want to be iconic it's my goal
my goal is to inspire that's my job I'm
a
[Music]
messenger true happiness is finding
yourself knowing who you are what is
your purpose on this Earth and doing
music and making a living doing what I
love when my heart is filled with music
I wake up I think about music I sing
music I talk to people I'm singing I'm
always trying to write a song I hear
like noise from the streets I hear
music longboarding is like a motorcycle
in me it's like on the edge you know
riding through traffic free not strapped
to anything you're just surfing surfing
the night way what do I love about la hm
Umami Burger in Hollywood you know I
have yet to find a burger that beats
Umami Burger you know my favorite meals
breakfast and I guess Gourmet fast food
and that's what Umami is absolutely
amazing it just goes to show all that
practicing in my bedroom all that
singing is well worth it cuz I'm here
now this is the dream come true it's so
different from New Orleans the lights
the sky the hills feel like a king
especially when you're like when you're
on a hill like mull you're looking down
to the city while I'm here I'm
[Music]
here